and I still remember
this feeling very clearly that I thought I
just had money and I could
just spend it on make-up for the first time because
before I had to spend every penny
somehow and save for a long time
on certain make-up products  to
be like the American YouTubers
but that was really a real
moment in my life where I thought so
wow I can somehow do anything.
Welcome to the OMR podcast
today
wasn't that accessible but I learned we have
a German star who is a person who
comes from Germany who
is very successful internationally on YouTube and
has a very unusual story
and she is very welcome here today
um Naomi John high no no hi
What's going on  So most of them are just as I
imagined or heard. Some
will be quickly surprised that you
're German. Many people don't even know that
because they're following you on the internet, or
at least most people are
already so used to me
speaking English that they'll then  So when
Naomi speaks German, she's somehow a
completely different person, I'm
not actually there, but somehow
it seems like it's crazy that
people only know me to speak English,
but actually you were born as a
completely normal girl in Göttingen
a completely normal girl
but yes Göttingen but I do
n't have that much of a connection to
Göttingen now I'm not like
all of me is my beautiful hometown
I left relatively quickly but you
started with the social media
experiments yes experiments that's
actually true  quite well, but
I only really started with social media
when I moved to Hanover
and started my training as a
media designer and then you realized
through the job that you
could do stuff like that on the internet and you said, okay, I'm
doing it more and more intensively now  yes, it was
before that, so I was always a
very
media-savvy girl, so I
used to have a block, I've
always done a lot, I've
always bought SLR cameras,
so I saved a lot for them, it was
n't so easy back then and that's why
I've always been interested in it and
back then I don't know if that still
means anything but musical.ly Talk yes, you know what
you're familiar with. That's when I
uploaded my first make-up videos and there
wasn't that much
make-up back then  Videos that means I was
already thinking, oh God, have I
found such a gap in the market here, I'm now
the first real make-up creator
who also does crazy make-up and then there
was demand for
people to do that too
Of course I also wanted to see YouTube videos, so
musical.ly and YouTube then musical.ly
and then comments kinomicke make-up
troll and YouTube
and then I also thought I
have to make English videos
because then I only have those
I have English comments so that's how it
came together that I
then made English videos,
okay,
that's interesting until now,
so to speak, I grew up normally with English at
school and then somehow
something in the aupair year, I think in England and
you're tight there  Actually, that's
what you
learn in Germany today as English and but
with that you're
obviously that's enough, that's good enough or you
're talented enough to
inspire international audiences, so to speak, so I would say that
Jan England really appealed to me  helped a lot
and I always say if I hadn't
been there I wouldn't have
made any videos in English because I would
n't have had this conference
to have such normal conversations in English
with the camera in that case and of course my
English isn't perfect but it is
In any case, it's already so normal for
me
to speak German English in Germany, that's
just the way my life is and
okay then what started then
you know, 20 21 something like that, just younger,
probably training again, I
think  I was 19
20 years old but 20 and that's already
yes yes no that was yesterday
[laughter]
Hide social media from my parents
I read
yes I was still super young so that
was really back in my
blogging days back then and  I
always posted pictures of myself and
I was still a minor and
I didn't really check what you
should and shouldn't show about yourself and
what kind of people there are on the Internet. I
just posted my art
like that  how I want to post them
and that's why I still remember the
conversation with my father back
then who said I
saw Block so you have to be careful what you
show yourself, it was
n't anything bad in itself but just for that
age, it's just you  shows up with
a lot of make-up or somehow in
some kind of outfits yes,
I didn't really check it out, that's why
it was a bit
yes I did, I just didn't
check it but now of course I'm a
bit older and now I can do
it  look back and know you have to
look at what you leave out of yourself in
class on the internet, but
so to speak, because we were just
talking about responsibility, that you address a
little bit of social
issues because they don't have to do with
climate change, political issues, anything
sustainability or something like that
you a topic or do you say that's that
it doesn't have a number one spot to no so
I'm actually a very a a
channel that's very much based on entertainment and
content so I don't want
the people who are already
dealing with things like that in their lives  then also
on my channel I
want to be that moment where they
can say now I'm switching off now
I can finally think about something else now
I'm looking at Naomi like she's noodles
or something like that that's just my
mission
is cool
[  Laughter]
no, I tend to eat un- and yes, that's
my thing too, that I really
like to test unhealthy things on
YouTube
[music]
yes, and above all, I work out
these recipes with
about 5 kilos of cheese and  So okay, what do
you mean, you somehow
started musical.ly in English, make-up things,
so now I understand
English make-up, but I've always been
fascinated by putting on make-up,
dressing, I mean that's what
we're seeing now  Some of you here
are going to listen to us, you're
kind of a bit unusual, so you've got more eye-catching
make-up than normal on the Hamburg
S-Bahn, so I think it's a lot of slap on my
face and my hair, anything that
works, but yeah, I've
always had fun  I also remember back when I was
11, I think I would have
put on a really big lip gloss and
a big, colorful necklace to school
and somehow
the teachers didn't let me walk around and that's what
I thought, why actually
it got me  really hurt then
I didn't do it at first but then
I just have to suppress it so I
always wanted to
dress crazy and you
lived that out in my videos that's exactly what came
back later when I started with social
media, I did too
noticed that I can express myself more
because people then want to see that, in
contrast to my teachers back then and that's
why I was finally able to
really develop my style and my character
through social media. I
always have no matter what kind of video I
shoot  Now what to cook
or I try out some
products People always comment
Naomi's make-up is really nice again today
or her hair looks good so
there will always be attention to the tell so
people will appreciate it which means
people will be upset but no  In
any case, there is a community, yes, and
it happened relatively quickly, so there was something in
the musical very early on
and then I brought it straight
to the front, so to speak, or it
lasted until then, so to speak, you are currently
over a million on Instagram
or  what's the most important channel
at the moment? YouTube, in any case,
you're there 2.5
million, but it's
progressing quickly now.
That's a good question. I do
n't have a comparison. I have the feeling that
somehow, but it actually happened
relatively quickly  On the
other hand, because I
had my training, I couldn't
devote myself completely to the whole thing because at
some point I had
these two full-time jobs at the same
time and somehow had to watch
my training during the week and then
YouTube videos and social media on the weekend
Media, it was definitely crazy,
but I wouldn't do anything else
and did you sit in the apartment
alone in Hanover and then
produce something with you and the camera and then upload it
all alone, yes, I lived at the time  I'm
also still with
my best friend, Winzer, who
has always supported me, who
then started with YouTube,
so I wasn't alone, but
technically, yes, and then things progressed.
You
immediately decided after the training, okay, that's it, then
I'll do it  it was
full-time or was there a transition phase
or when was it clear to you that
it was actually the same, so it had
already developed a lot and was established
during my training that,
fortunately, after my training I had the privilege of
being able to say full-time
social media and I was so happy about that
now  How many followers
do you need or when is it
enough to have a full-time job, so to speak?
So I don't think you
can measure Anna's specific follower numbers,
but rather on your income, but
that depends on us, we have to do it together or yes,
definitely, but I think  It
also depends on which platform you
are on because on YouTube, because I
upload a YouTube video every week,
I somehow have something like a
constant income that varies
a little but that basically pays
my rent if I were just on
TikTok or  Only on Instagram
you don't get any money for
views or you can't advertise like that
on YouTube
and that's why without the security
of YouTube I don't even know whether
I would have done it that way with my
main job  Then it always pays out
through the advertising that you
put into your videos, exactly yes, and at the
beginning you can get a few thousand
euros a month of something like that or
how do you have to imagine so I remember at the
very beginning when I had my
first crack  paycheck
I think I got a million views on
the Christmas make-up tutorial
and um I think I
somehow got around 2000 € or something
and that was also
around Christmas and me and my family had been
in it for a long time  New York trip
planned and then I had this 2000 €
and I was in America and then I was
a make-up Lanz I don't know if that
says of course it's a really big address
and that didn't exist in Germany back then
and I still remember
Exactly this feeling that I
thought I just had money and I
could just spend it on
make-up for the first time because before I had to
turn every money around
and save for a long time on certain
make-up products in order to be like them
American Youtuber but that was
really a real moment in
my life where I thought, wow, I
can somehow do anything and then
you bought yourself make-up for €2000, which was
n't that great, so I
also saved a bit  Because
I've just moved to Hanover at the moment,
but I already have around 300, 400 €,
I already have
a monthly
uff, that's a good question, so
luckily I'm not just doing make-up
content anymore and I also have a lot
Make-up at home, which I also
need, which means I don't actually buy as much anymore
as you
might think, so it does
n't run out that quickly, so before
we got started I asked you for
your best performance video
most viewers asked and there's
one that you painted on yourself with
freckles and then
tried to get them off and it didn't come
off and then you had it on for a few days
and just like that in front of the camera
and it got 10 million, yes that
was it  So really this moment where
I had a breakthrough for
me personally on YouTube because I
also noticed in which direction I
wanted to go, testing out things with
myself, I
made a lot of videos afterwards,
shaving off eyebrows, dyeing hair,
dyeing it  I really noticed so
oh that's actually totally driving that's what
I want to do even if I do
n't want to do that freckle again now
so okay you're not paying any
attention to your body exactly
but what kind of permanent
damage have you suffered from it no that's
why it's  The good thing, most of it
grows after it goes away, that's why
I think it's all a
lot more chill than you think, but
make-up is probably a relatively
strong vertical, so that's
attractive in terms of sales because there are
potential advertising customers and so on
true, but that's why I mean,
I was never really a
make-up YouTuber on YouTube, so I actually
tested drugstore products every month or best praders
of the week or I don't know, it was
always more like what I do on Instagram
a lot of make-up tutorials but
on YouTube it's more like entertainment. Describe
a bit for someone who does
n't know each other yet, what do you do
on YouTube? Yes, um yes, I
actually do everything I feel like doing,
from cooking to
trying out things. I buy funny clothes
for my cats I buy funny
clothes for myself
I test food in IKEA so there are
really
100,000 people on the videos exactly yes and
what you also have a lot of community
working with then always
answer the comments super closely
so I try to do it for everyone
So, especially when it's just been
uploaded, I
always try to actively chat, but it's not
that easy and most of the people who
follow are Americans or me.
Yes, it's very well distributed on YouTube.
I would say I have around 40  %
from Germany and 60% from all over the
world so that's just really
broken down a few are from many a
few are from Spain fit from the
Czech Republic so it's really ever I
was on holiday in Italy at Lake Como last year in
our tiny  small village
that I don't know so maybe a few
and then there was the waitress in the café
videos I love you
now I met him here so
I'm telling you it's really very
nested somewhere everything always looks
from that musical.ly and
phase back then  came about
so that was definitely the origin
whether they still have my musical.ly videos on
yes and how does an
Italian person like that find themselves there on Lake Como, how do they
find them today I don't
even know how to ask how did you find me
YouTube algorithm somehow  So
to say, to catch him flushing your videos
forward or are you
consciously doing something to
grow internationally, no, just 100%.  Yes,
it is of course very important
that you go to the
Explorer page on YouTube at the beginning and are
recommended. This way you generate
new ones, that is, that is
very important and that is why
video ideas are always super
important to me personally  Not only is, for
example, I'm testing food in Berlin, so it does
n't appeal to everyone,
otherwise it won't bring something to everyone, um,
but it
can be a bit more international and also
appeal to Thundercity very much,
so it always has to be a perfect picture  I
have in my head where I say
I'm shooting this video now, how many people
are in your team these days?
I have an editor who makes
rough cuts, so he always throws
out everything that's so unnecessary, but I
still edit my videos myself, so
I want to do that too  Put emphasis on it because
that's very important to me and
I'm interested in a lot of work,
but in general I'm so for my content
for my content I'm okay then
you have quite a few partnerships in the agency that I have with the
water
so if you're like that  Look at a whole
list, I think somehow from DM
Rossmann Zalando, so all of them with a wide
variety of cooperation, exactly so
I don't do a lot of cooperation
but I have a lot of projects
going on, of course I have my agency
BWM, it's a shame
exactly my managers and you can get them
then that's exactly why and
now it's like this, you've been living on it so far, so
I assume income millionaire,
how do you define that over a million
already very well of it yes, I definitely ca
n't complain about
more than you
could ever have achieved with classic media design
I'm also very happy
that I don't have to sit in an agency at the
computer every day,
but I don't want to do it for myself and you're
now making, so to speak, in terms of the content
output on YouTube, it's not
that many videos per week, so to speak
I recently had June
here umm doing but also so he
could breathe but he does it every day he
says to do something um so
a difference with you is as normal
as long approximately so I do both
but mainly long form and that
means in  across and at least 20 minutes
and I always sit on the edit for a day or two
then I sit on the shoot for a day
and if I upload once a week that
's already three days gone,
okay, but then you somehow have an
idea and you're looking for an editorial area, so to speak
listening for
content ideas and I always have a
note where I write down content ideas for myself,
so I plan everything like
two three months in advance for next
week because it's memorized, yes,
testing tiktok make-up products or tiktok food
So recipes that you find on tiktok
I do a lot of tiktok related
things that I then
test on YouTube okay awesome so how do
you interact with this platform you
look at 50 as you look at tiktok
you see somehow an essence idea
and say  then hey I think that's
cool now I'll cook it in detail
and 50 too and then it will be a
YouTube video exactly and that
actually works very well so YouTube and
TikTok are so good
and everyone has seen it and thinks
okay then you can  you play that, what's
coming the next week?
I'd actually have to watch it again now
because I don't have that
in mind right now, okay, but have you already
planned any crazy things for the next few weeks that you
already know? Well, I
always like to do that  Also very long videos
that last one to two hours
where I actually test
make-up, I said at the beginning I do
n't test make-up on YouTube, that's
now a complete contradiction but
apparently yes, but then that's it
A bit of a special format where I,
for example, test all of
Prince's luxurious make-up in one video
and that's why it's really two
hours long because I always
give background information and
really do a review and that's why
it's such a huge chunk but I
love it  Such long videos are not for
everyone but my lost ones like that
in any case give up on such a video
how many people watch if you look at it, I guess it's
already around two million
and that's, um, in terms of age so
probably a lot of women
and  then everyone is about
teenage age or so mine is
my my my target group is I would
say 20 to 28 somehow in the shoot so
like me
yes so the musician yes I have also been a
musician for two years
I think your parents were already
musicians too  My father is
actually still a musician, my
mother is no longer a
media designer, but I
also grew up with music, a very
classic case and I always wanted
to be a singer, but I
always thought that was unattainable
because it was for me  that really then about
DSDS what do I do then how do I become a
singer and I've already
got that on my head, I'm
not going to anyway so I didn't have that
self-confidence that I could say
that's where I'm going at some point but when
I started with social  When I started media,
I noticed, oh, I have
an oriental woman who is interested in me,
maybe she'll also be interested in my
music and luckily it's
something like
pop music but also in English, so that
means you sing somehow and but
guitar or  something or just sing or
so I sing and performance
video so now you basically have to
generate a quick podcast in here and
then
your biggest song is called like you no, that
was my first single and so the first
single is of course always the biggest
hype because it  People want to know what
she's doing, what's coming because it's embarrassing,
of course they also want to maybe
that's embarrassing,
no, it's definitely written so
something about Spotify I think it was a 30
minute stream,
I mean I watched it
wait wait wait
artist slipped  no, I'm just
not with Spotify streams, 6 million
streams
okay,
20% of someone's okay, but when I
say on the parking platform, I pay immediately
what I'm
missing
I had
only planned one concert for September, just to try it out and see.
It
's in Berlin, it's there too, but then
the demand was very high, it
sold out immediately and now I've
expanded it to four other cities:
Hamburg, Cologne, Munich and London  where are
you playing now in Hamburg for example
or Berlin
no in Hamburg asked in Berlin it's
Hall forty four in Hamburg in Cologne it's a
canteen in Hamburg I can
tell you later but there
were probably hundreds to 1000 people
yes that's probably around
600 people yes  Something like that, so
now I want to start small and see
what the response is and then
next year I have an album and then
Europe or maybe even a world
tour planned, but that's all still
roller skating, yes it feels crazy, but we
thought like that  so why
not no so if I actually have
so many Orients in l.a. New York in
Australia I also have a lot
if I have them you do
n't have to sell out a huge stadium now
but why so I think
38.9500
I'm not there yet  At the label
I do everything myself in the pennend there
is a lot of cost involved so
I'll probably end up with a
loss so it's a community
event a gift to the community than
that somehow they know it is so that's it
I don't make any profit from it,
but for me it's simply my
biggest dream
because I want to wake you up, so
as a singer and I mean that's
no one can get bigger quickly, so
if she is that too, that's the goal
but that means medium and long term
Do you actually want to be a musician rather
than a content creator? Difficult question.
I'll say no because I love my
job, I love my followers, I love
my ordiens, I love my YouTube,
um that's why I always say I want to
be established as both, I want to be
taken seriously as both  I do
n't want to be a YouTuber who
makes music, but I also don't want
to be a musician who, wait a minute,
I actually want to
be together, just to be taken seriously by both of them
You're
already thinking about what the next 15
years could look like for you, so
I already like it, it's
really difficult to do music and social
media at the same time, so my
content and the music because there's a
lot of time and money in both  That's
why I don't know
where it will lead if the
music ever gets bigger because it's already
so difficult, but it's
just my biggest dream so I ca
n't do anything stupid. Who are there?  I
want to inspire you that it's a
bit like your career, of course, in any
case,
why do you say Billie Eilish so a
certain assumption could be simple so
instinct
decent also great but actually
I like it more like that I'm more of a pop
direction I like German Cat I like
Aschen  Nico, I don't know if you
know Ash Nico, you see my biggest
role model, she's also become known on tiktok, um, yeah,
exactly, I'm more like my
dad, and I'm also
more
international, so not in Germany,
okay, what does that mean?  you look at how they
do it and then that should be
inspiration for you
and do you think that in the next few
years, if you have careers like yours, it
's a
bit surprising to me today, but there are always things like that on the
right and the left
create like that or that's
something unusual, actually no, yes,
although I know a few
cases who started out as YouTubers
and then became musicians
were [ __ ]. I don't know if you were told that,
okay, um, but still the people who
start with YouTube and then  Musicians will
then also make music, so they have
n't continued with YouTube
and I just don't want to
do it that way, I just want to
keep both running and that's why
I don't know where that
is the case, so I know I know  a lot of
influenza who also make music
but I don't know how serious they are when they
say that it should definitely
stay that way now
or I'll just post a single like that
and then that's fine,
you really want to follow music at full throttle,
full throttle
you did something like that Shirin David
is in that area and it
seems to me that your career is a bit
similar, from YouTube to
music, yes, but it's
really from YouTube to music, so you do
n't see YouTube anymore, you're now
full of blood, a musician and that  I do
n't want to do that, so I'm still doing it
okay, but Instagram and that's
exactly what you do, but as a
musician you also do Instagram, that's something
different. I'm really talking about
my content that my followers
expect every Sunday, okay  Sunday is always
release day Sunday is
release day Youtube yes and Friday music
okay how many how many songs are there
already um I think I've
published six now yes and then
next year so something like that lyrics yourself you
do everything yourself exactly but then just go
with it  My Bluetooth then together
sometimes we seemed to add a song along
with it so I need a
bit of support so that you can
find melodies, especially in
English, so easy as a German person,
it's always good to have languages ​​with you,
especially for grammatical things,
but that's why  I'm definitely
at the start everywhere, so at the
end of the day you're now a brand,
so you do all your brand development
completely alone, so the
question now is I'm going
on tour, which locations do I play, how
do I set the prices,
which partnerships  Do I go in, do you make
the decision alone or are
there people in your environment who can
advise me in some way, so management
probably otherwise yes, I
make a lot of decisions on my own,
many of them but of course there
are also agreements with my management so
that they advise me  I've known me
for many years,
Vincent, who I live with, my
best friend, who I actually
ask about every [ __ ] whether it's you
posting this picture or posting this picture,
so he's always there, he
's always in a music video
Music video Dresden he's on tour with
us um that's actually
the two parties that I always wear
and are there any partnerships that
you might be interested in
financially so something like that has been around
for a long time and for you, so to speak,
from your girlfriend the economic
backbone for you  So somehow a
particularly prominent role
for you is played by cooperation or some
companies that support each other in the end:
yes, you currently live in
front of it, music implementation of partnerships
or
yes, actually I live more from
YouTube, i.e. the whole hodgepodge of
companies that advertise there, the YouTubers
Reinhold, these are your solutions exactly.
As I said, I'm not such a
collab mouse that I do so many paid
collaborations on Instagram or something like that.
I'm very piki,
I don't know, I only do it when
I feel like I can integrate it really
well  I'm completely
behind it, it's not unnatural and
I have to do it like that, so there's
a lot of deception involved where I then say
no, that doesn't come across well at all or
it's kind of a strange product, that's
why I tend to keep my
distance from it and can be happy that  I
can just post YouTube videos and
make money that way and the
stream stuff is that interesting, do
you mean music streaming or
what? Well, I actually
started playing with Vincent on
Twitch.
I noticed, oh, that's just too
much  In addition, I
'm already very busy and do
n't have a lot of free time
and then every Sunday evening, when that
's actually the only free evening
I have in the week,
sitting in front of the camera and watching streams
didn't work for me
You write in the scripts, so to speak,
and edit here, but that's
exactly from the morning, so that takes up
a lot of time. I always have to
go on vacation every time I have something planned. I don't really go
on vacation very often, I always think I
still have to  I have to shoot a video beforehand,
I still have to edit it, now also
a video right now where I am right now,
no, I definitely
always have to plan a lot of time
for it and otherwise there are
all the other
music projects  There's so much planning, especially
for the tour and for the album and doing song
sessions and then just
kind of chatting in there, you
kind of see that it never stops, so
say when the year is over, the first
week of the new year is here again
and  The next video has to come out, yes, you
ask good questions in any case, so
I'm already under pressure, especially now,
even after six and seven years of
doing this, I can say it's
always such a constant pressure on you,
I kind of like the pressure, but
sometimes not, so it's
difficult, I have to say, but I think
the perspective is now it's
going to go on like this for years, yes, but the
good thing is that even though there's this pressure,
I love what I do, so
it's my good pressure  the pressure that
I have chosen
would take a break for a few weeks then it is immediately
a danger because the
reach will then be lost, that the community will be
disappointed and that somehow you
can actually afford it,
going on vacation is difficult, yes, you are right,
so it is  To be
honest, I don't dare do it, but I know
a lot of podcasters who
take a summer break and recently I
thought, why don't I do that?
I ca
n't afford it, so people do
n't like my videos  look more
or that the algorithm
will do something so this fear you've
always
written a book yes,
God, if you wrote this
a year and a half ago
tell me how it came about so that was
a slightly different book a slightly
unconventional book I  I
had this idea from the beginning that I
would like to do a book that
represents my YouTube channel because I
said at the beginning that I had
tried a lot on my body and had
done a lot of creative things
and that's why I wanted to do that with this
book  Follower Channel that they
do the same thing and at least
have this motivation and then it
became a challenge book with 111
challenges that were basically all taken from my
YouTube channel, not all
but very, very many and
people should then do them and that's what I got
Then they also did a contest so that
they could then submit the challenges, they
could film what they
could win. The other day I
cashed in the main prize. There were two of the
two winners in Berlin
with me the whole weekend. The men had to do a few challenges,
so I mean if you  Having the right
product isn't that
bad, I think when everyone
lost mine from my video, what do
you do,
try this hairstyle or go out
in a bright color for a whole day
or
go out on the street and sing a song
about something like that  Something in this direction
where you have to jump over your shadow
and that's what
people did and it sold how often do
you know
what I don't now but a
lot of people have definitely done it, it
was really crazy, all of that
Well, I personally looked through all
the challenges that were submitted,
which is why
the evaluation took so long. It
was nice to see how people
really do what I write in this
book. It was really cool
in the end  Actually, you already have responsibility or you do
n't have to jump in from the
window or something like
that, that's an expression of how seriously
or how strongly your community listened to it and
implements what you want, yes, that's
true, but it's more like it's
meant to be  as a motivation that they
don't have to do anything, but
simply because everyone always says when
my videos are like that, I think it's so cool
that you dare to do so much and this
book was exactly for that,
everyone can actually have the courage,
you can do it too,
okay
There's something else on the list that I did
n't trust yet,
so the bald head is already on the
list, really
okay,
wow, but I mean you also have
wigs and stuff like that. Well, you don't think it's
all that bad,
probably yes  Do you ever have a
bridge task? It's really annoying but I
know some of them so I don't know myself
anymore. Well then I don't know how it
feels because especially in the summer it's
really [ __ ], yes that's
true or I just don't wear
wigs and wear my bald one in the racer  Head
then it's
actually really cool,
I know if I dare to do that because
you get the feeling that it's somehow very
shitty.
No, not necessarily, but for me
it's just that my hair, the fact that I
can undy it like that, has always been my thing
and if it  then suddenly they're gone
then it's somehow my
my trademark is gone strange in the
morning I
really
understand that make-up but
a new hair color every day
then there was a limit that okay
today is green and today is red yes so
mostly  then just a few tips
or something like that because it does
n't wash out for a long time but in principle
yes and making your own products I
mean most
creators these days
after a certain amount of time with such a
large community at some point and say
okay, I do  I'm now making my own in
your case, I think there's still a
fragrance but my own beauty products, my own
clothes, my own who then
becomes an entrepreneur myself but I'm
also leaving her so earlier, in any
case, I always wanted to have my own
make-up brand but I  I have to say
not anymore today, um somehow it's
been so much in the background because
now the music is my baby, it's
now my product, so to speak, that I
want to focus on
and that's why everything else has somehow
faded into the background.
I still really like perfume  important um but
you do that with your partner
exactly and
last year I made two fragrances and then
maybe another one will come this year
and I also make an
app with it if he does the lashes they
also do make-up.  product is or not
my own brand, so to speak, and mine
can
be of an order of magnitude, so how much sales do
you make,
how do you mean now, how expensive one
is, do
you know the numbers, so that will be
with yours, you don't know them
Face,
it's written somewhere but I ca
n't remember it now but it was
good, but then someone needs to
vent then I
once discussed it with Jeremy's friends, he
thinks very much about his own performance and
then judges it himself that
she  I liked one and then
had a perfume like that that she
told me. For
me it's maybe not quite as
bad as for Jeremy Freddance. For me
it's just more like that. I get
a lot of them so I give an impetus in
which direction I should go  want what kind of
courage I want to have with the scent and
then I get
sent a lot of samples then I say
that I like the temple that I
like that I give feedback then
I get new very very very
many samples again  Then I test them for
days, so something like that and you can
buy it in the store or online, you can
probably
speak to Douglas on DM with all of them now,
okay better your partner cura okay
and you told me that then
American fans are angry because they  Being able to get that
personally, yes,
I imagine it would be
frustrating because I
have a big fan base and then when I
publish a product and they
notice, I don't get it at all, that
's just [ __ ] for them, but we're
working on it  Well, you
said
that you don't have to do that much
cooperation, then you already have
a bit of
interest, I somehow saw on the
list what that is, then
you just say that you
talk about it, you do it  It
really always depends on what kind of
campaign they have, so I
always really read into it for the shower,
I had done a make-up look at the time,
so they had
a sound that
I could use straight away  such
an idea of ​​what I can do with make-up
because if I can combine make-up with
the product and it
just works and is not and is of
course forested then that's great
then I like to do
a little bit of the secret at the end
It's with the broccoli that
plays a big role,
yes, but it's so unspectacular when
people ask me about it. I've been calling all
my followers broccoli for
years and I think it was
just because I think I
asked Vincent what should I have for
dinner  eat what should I
eat for dinner he always said
broccoli I
said funny so no not
tattoos are something like that yes but you can do that
now simply because my
broccoli is so important to me okay
that's relatively small
broccoli literature
I don't have a bigger one now
can impress
but then I'm just doing it for you
but tattoos aren't your thing, no,
I've had an ass wall for
a while now or yes since last year
I've already got a lot of tattoos you ca
n't tell yet that's what it says for me
I have a song here that
means cute in Japanese,
the color is actually a bit like that,
it all comes back and
I have a bit of a convention ass
because I don't know if I
want to hold it in the camera but it's a
bit like triple  Moderately, but that's
how it was before, in the Müller years, but
if you look at my
Instagram then you know that it's a bit more
modern, but it doesn't matter,
you've already
somehow reported on TV about yourself,
I mean, you've somehow  It was
fun for joiners, no, yes, for
joining, I basically released my own
format a few weeks ago,
but I'm not really into television yet,
but who knows what's to come, so a
bit like that, but the dance show
I say would always be there  I'm taking part,
yes, so RTL if you're watching, I'm sure
some of them are, so that means you can
imagine it, so let's dance, so I'm really up for it, but
then I really have to
train, or am I
up for it, or are you also cool
with it, but you're also showing off  Bald head says
that's okay, are there any
platforms?
Yes, it's just another thing
like with Twitch, where I thought
I could start, but then
I'm afraid that because there's time, I
just won't be able to do it and
then I'll need it too  don't start,
what will your life be like in 10 15 years,
what do you think is exactly the same, really,
hopefully a little bit, I've
developed further but I hope I'm
still doing exactly the same, do I have to do
that because I'm a woman or
what? No, that's not my goal  To be honest, the fact that
I'll switch to that at some point
is a long
way off for me too, so I don't see myself there at all. I
just do my thing the way I
do it today, in the best case scenario it's
further developed because you ca
n't always do the same content.
I don't do it either  the same content as
6 years ago
so that they can stay with you for
the next 10 years yes if I always ask for
new ideas and good content yes that's how
I've opened it so far and do
you look at any key
figures and then  Do you have
a certain worry or
are you now totally sure and and
so it would be a lie if
I said I did
n't look at it, I had no
overview and you're always worried,
I said yes, you always have this pressure
So of course I look at this algorithmic pressure,
but I ca
n't complain, I'm super happy,
especially on YouTube, that's just my
platform, my thing is, um,
but
mine,
yes, definitely no, everything's still
good
as an artist, I mean  If you didn't think about it that way, you would have had
the chance to
continue to become big as an artist and to
become big internationally and if the type of
music is really exactly as a
singer then yes if that happens then that's what
happens
then I say  also no,
everything has to stay the same, what comes what
comes, as I
said, so it's also my biggest
dream,
so
for me it's you notice my
questions,
a new world the way it
works, it's also international, yeah,
cool, so I really think it's an
amazing possibility  So 20 years ago you would
n't have had it under any circumstances
and now you can do it like that
[music]
in Germany so you could
see more if you do that at some point
Florence residents just to
save taxes then the precautionary
okay
would be obvious, yes, but I think LA,
for example, is really bad as far as you are
concerned with the influenza scene. I think it's so,
I was in LA for a while, I
met a few and I thought that
was it  two weeks and I
think it's very fake, I have to say, so
I don't like this whole superficial fake
tour, maybe I'm
too old for that now. I don't know, it
's just me, I don't like it anymore, that's
why I'm staying in Germany, I
like Germany  I
'm going to get to know a
little bit now, um,
so since yesterday I think or so, um,
I'm going to keep a little eye on it
[music]
[laughter]
hello to all the broccolis is
Philippe
how much how much
comment are you writing on Sunday so how
much or how  a lot of DM responsibility,
not that many, so I don't look
at it very often either, just when I
post a new video I
reward those who are also active and
join in straight away, but I do
n't have that much of an annoyance for it then there's so much  So I
learned again that he really also has
influenza then actually
work harder in the community and really
answer DMS answer comments but
that's for you too but I would
n't say that I'm doing it somehow
pathologically every single
comment at every EM so I
'll try that  It just doesn't work
a day or something like that, so the
feeling that he spends 20, 30 to 2,300 a day is
normal
here, the Karo Kauer kammuschka, they
told me that in this really hardcore
community
he has
probably already built up a real mommy community and
I can understand how they always give advice,
but I would have the feeling that they do it,
so what do you want, but also because
maybe that's part of the business,
so if you do, everyone has to
define it for themselves,
I have the feeling  I have a
really close meaning to my broccoli,
but then in a different
way, whether it's the tour
or whether it's just really my content
that they get every Sunday,
so of course we get it from other influenza
too  but I already have
the feeling that we are really fatter
and your people me and my broccallys
no you and I mean I
now come on now be careful if I
somehow comment every Sunday immediately
after the launch
okay so yes
thank you very much for doing that  A
bit of Explorer might be a good idea, thanks
and all the best
[music]
and Hamburg
[laughter]
okay, thank you, ciao